Super Bowl tradition with a new twist
just before kickoff tomorrow and right
after the national anthem fans at State
Farm stadium in Arizona will be treated
to a very special Navy flyover four Jets
flown by seven women will join a list of
Super Bowl first while commemorating 50
years since women were allowed to be
Navy Pilots but before they make their
televised flyby these Pilots got another
test flying with our own Chris Van
Cleave
who joins us from State Farm Stadium
lucky guy with a behind the scenes look
Chris good morning
good morning arguably their biggest test
was putting up with me in the back seat
there but these are highly trained
highly skilled Pilots that have been you
know honing these Aviation skills for
years they've flown combat missions this
will probably be their highest profile
Mission ever they even put up with the
occasional civilian in the back seat but
they're also furthering a legacy of
women on the flight deck
taking off from Luke Air Force Base
Lieutenant Peggy Dente is getting ready
for what will be the highest profile
mission of her Navy career buzzing State
Farm Stadium right after the national
anthem have you done a flyover before I
have not no it's my first one small
stage for a first flyover yeah no
pressure nervous you know I think it'd
be crazy if you weren't a little bit
nervous but a little bit of nerves keeps
you honest keeps you humble keeps you
focused on the mission Sunday's four
fighter flyover will have an all-woman
team of seven as the Navy celebrates 50
years of female Pilots it wasn't until
1973 when eight women were first allowed
to enter flight school six earned their
wings about a year after graduating
Rosemary Mariner became the first woman
assigned to Pilot a Navy fighter women
now make up about 15 percent of Naval
aviators it is not lost on me how
special it is that I get to do what I'm
doing today because they did it first
the significance of this Super Bowl
first wasn't lost some of the NFL's
greats several Hall of Famers visited
the pilots and their support Crews
Thursday to thank them for their service
it's definitely a huge honor to be asked
to do this and to celebrate those women
that have paved this way for all of us
Lieutenant's Ariel Ash and Sheree Moreno
will be leading the diamond formation I
don't think we have any question about
the execution of it I think it's going
to go just a plan because you have to be
there at down to the second that's
correct we're used to the mission maybe
not so much used to the publicity
Pilots have had a couple weeks to
prepare including this Friday practice
flight but first lieutenant Dente is
showing us what her ea-18 Growler can do
that which meant pulling a 6G turn
that's six times the force of gravity
pressing down upon us
and apparently it's not a True Flight if
you don't go upside down how did I do
you did really well Chris I didn't throw
up I didn't pass out no neither of those
things I think you did great Dante fell
in love with Aviation as a kid learning
to fly with her dad the inspiration to
join the Navy came from her grandfather
who flew helicopters in Vietnam now she
and the rest of these Pilots get a
chance to inspire a new generation of
aviators I think it's a message not just
to young girls but to young people that
they can do whatever they set their mind
to and if they want to be a Jet Pilot
that is well within the possibility for
them
and obviously these flyovers don't just
happen there's been a ton of
coordination with the FAA the NFL the TV
production to make sure this all happens
right at the right moment they're
confident they will execute this Mission
I have to tell you guys one thing that I
was struck by Peggy and her electronic
warfare officer the person who sits in
the back seat where I was sitting
they've known each other since college
and I have to say they are fellow USC
Trojan Alum so fight on
about that I was trying to figure out
Chris how you were going to get that in
there because I saw you tweet that
earlier in the week
gotta love it I'm obligated I was
obligated to do it fight on he followed
the keys don't throw up don't pass out
nice job as you well know there you go
Dana yeah all three of us welcome to the
club it knows Jesus great story and it's
always fun to watch those